bonjour La voix est Libre en direct tous
les samedis sur France 3 avec
aujourd'hui une voix bourguignonne qui a
fait parler d'elle dans tout le pays à
la fin de l'été François Rebsamen
bonjour bonjour ministre du Travail
depuis avril 2014 vous avez décidé après
le décès d'Alain Millau à la fin du mois
de juillet de revenir à Dijon donc vous
aviez été le maire depuis 2001 on va
parler du ministère du Travail de la
situation nationale des prochaines
élections régionales aussi et bien sûr
de Dijon et chez vous vous pouvez réagir
sur notre site internet dans l'article
consacré à l'émission François fmen
votre décision a surpris dans l'opinion
c'est un cas quasiment unique quitté le
gouvernement sans y être obligé pour
retourner dans sa ville en général c'est
quand on est viré qu'on fait ça vous
avez mis en avant la promesse que vous
aviez fait au dijonnais fait au
dijonnais mais est-ce qu'on doit pas y
voir aussi une forme de message je
rentre chez moi j'envoie tout promener
non je voudrais d'abord rappeler mais
vous l'avez fait dans quelle
circonstances cela s'est produit d'abord
il y a eu le décès d'Alain Millau un
décès qui m'a profondément touché
affecté je le dis et j'avais pris un
engagement auprès auprès d'Alain et des
Dijonnais mais aussi auprès d'Alain lui
est lui seul me remplaçait et s'il ne
pouvait plus être mère pour une raison
ou une autre on n'avait jamais envisagé
cette fin bien sûr je reviendrai et donc
j'ai essayé de le dire d'une manière la
plus détendue possible pour enlever
l'émotion j'ai dit j'avais promis de
revenir et bien me revoilà c'est une
période qui a été difficile à titre
personnel ça vous a plus touché
peut-être que vous ne l'avez montré à ce
moment-là oui oui il y avait une disons
que ça a été émotionnellement assez fort
oui même très fort tout de même vous
appartenez au premier cercle de François
Hollande Françoise
2012 vous n'êtes pas ministre 2014 vous
irez 2012 j'ai refusé vous refusez 2014
vous héritez d'un portefeuille à risque
très compliqué
est-ce que on doit évacuer la notion de
d'amertume de votre part et de dire je
rentre à Dijon j'en ai assez
complètement j'étais dans un ministère
que j'avais choisi en 2012 ministère
extrêmement difficile mais un beau
ministère un grand ministère pour un
homme de gauche et avec la certitude de
faire un travail
utile et donc c'est avec beaucoup de
regrets beaucoup de regrets je le dis
que j'ai quitté le ministère mais
permettez-moi de le dire c'est avec
beaucoup de joie que je suis à Dijon
mère parce que c'est d'abord c'est le
plus beau des mandats contrairement à ce
que dit presse parisienne être mère
c'est pas une chose simple ce qui
préoccupait de la vie des gens au
quotidien dans la proximité imaginez la
vie l'évolution d'une ville c'est pas
simple il y a que les Parisiens qui
pensent que c'est on voit toujours
qu'une carrière c'est une absence une
ascension Françoise on est maire d'une
grande ville ensuite on devient ministre
et puis ensuite on veut un plus grand
ministère la voix que vous avez prise
elle est totalement inhabituel ça fait
partie de ma personnalité moi je suis
attaché à cette ville ça se sait j'ai
construit plutôt alain a construit une
communauté urbaine j'en ai pris la
présidence
j'ai encore des choses des belles choses
à faire à Dijon pour les Dijonnais pour
cette ville voilà bien sûr aussi il y
avait pas eu le décès d'Alain je serai
resté jusqu'en 2017 le président m'a
demandé de rester voilà c'est une
question que j'avais président m'a
demandé de rester il m'a demandé comment
il a réagi quand vous lui avez dit ça
franchement ça le mettait dans les
ennuis quand même changer de ministre du
Travail à la fin de l'été une sorte de
faux vrai faux remaniement c'est clair
il m'a demandé s'il y avait d'autres
solutions et je lui ai dit que je ne
l'avais pas d'autre solution que de
respecter la parole que j'avais donnée
et donc voilà il m'a dit il était en
es-tu sûr tu as bien regardé voilà mais
ma détermination était c'est dans cette
recherche de solutions vous avez dit le
30 juillet je serai mère et ministre ce
qui a déclenché
pour la presse la presse quotidienne
celle qui inonde les ondes et les images
celles qui fait de du média zapping de
la télé zapping et donc voilà donc il
s'est tombé sur moi bon c'est j'ai remis
les choses en place dès le lendemain il
y avait un article dans un journal du
soir le monde où je précisais que bien
évidemment mais il y a un ministre qui
s'en est mêlés il y a même Manuel Valls
qui a donné son avis il a dit il a dit
qu'elle était la règle et vous l'avez
pas pris vous l'avez pris contre vous
non non je connais cela règle je connais
cela bien évidemment je n'avais parlé
avant au président de la République qui
m'avait demandé de ne pas de donner de
date de sortie de ne pas donner de date
de sortie voilà plus largement
on se souvient quand vous n'étiez pas
ministre sur ce même plateau vous nous
avez dit plusieurs fois on se rappelle
par exemple la visite de François
Hollande à Dijon qui s'était passé de
façon un peu tumultueuse ils savent pas
communiquer ils expliquent pas bien il
faut faire autrement on a le sentiment
que quand vous vous êtes retrouvé
ministre vous avez vécu la même chose
avec un certain nombre de polémiques de
rétropédalage ça veut dire quoi c'est
plus dur que vous ne le pensiez oui il y
a pas eu de sous la sous le gouvernement
de Manuel Valls il y a pas eu de quoi
contre ministre il y a eu des annonces
pour faire bouger les choses certaines
ont bougé je pourrais parler par exemple
du contrôle des chômeurs là-dessus ça
par exemple c'était jeter une annonce
pour faire avancer les choses pour faire
avancer le débat en sachant que vous
alliez prendre la marée médiatique
derrière il y avait une étude qui avait
été lancée une expérimentation qui avait
été lancée dans trois régions et qui
montrait que nombre de chômeurs ne
recherchaient plus d'emploi décrochait
pour des raisons très diverses soit
parce que là ils trouvaient pas d'emploi
soit parce que l'emploi qui trouvait
n'était pas celui qui correspond à leurs
besoins soit parce que ils avaient
complètement décroché dans la recherche
d'emploi et donc ça pouvait atteindre
des proportions notamment les chômeurs
de longue durée de l'ordre de 1 sur 2 et
donc pour être chômeur il faut chercher
du travail et le but des agents de
l'ANPE des conseillerspe enfin de la
Pôle Emploi vous voyez sur cette partie
là c'est justement d'aider ces gens à
raccrocher raccrocher les wagons savoir
pourquoi ils abandonnent et les retours
étaient très positifs de l'expérience
les retours étaient très positifs de ces
parce que c'est pas c'est pas la fraude
c'est autre chose c'est c'est le
contrôle pourquoi ces gens-là ne
cherchent plus alors que il s'abandonne
en partie la désespérance oui puis des
tas de raisons très différentes
familiales décrochage tout tout existé
on les remet dans le bain et je suis
très heureux de savoir que c'est étendu
voilà à partir de septembre ça
fonctionne les sondages disent l'opinion
publique était pour oui bien sûr et en
même temps la charge principale elle est
venue de votre partie du Parti
socialiste les frondeurs Martine Aubry
alors ça veut dire est-ce que ces
symptomatique quand même de de la
difficulté quel gouvernement aujourd'hui
avec son propre parti je comprends la
question c'est à dire que ça m'a surpris
l'autre jour j'écoutais une émission ou
Martine Aubry était à laquelle elle
participait et elle a dit mais le
contrôle des chômeurs c'est moi qui l'ai
mis en place en 1992 elle a dit ça
devant les journalistes et j'étais très
surpris de voir que les mêmes
journalistes ne réagissaient absolument
pas donc
beaucoup de gens qui elle a revendiqué
elle a revendiqué cela
je redis le contrôle des chômeurs savoir
pourquoi il cherche pas du travail ou il
ne cherche plus du travail c'est c'est
le travail des des conseillers de Pôle
emploi et quand on est surnom on doit
chercher du travail et donc c'est il
faut absolument les aider à se remettre
dans le bac même question vous avez fait
passer une loi sur le dialogue social on
avait beaucoup parlé des solutions on va
dire que la charge principale contre la
réforme des seuils sociaux elle est
venue des syndicats qui était dans le
rôle mais aussi de votre propre camp et
de votre propre parti politique est-ce
que ça d'une partie de la monomaniaque
mais est-ce que est-ce que ça résume la
difficulté aujourd'hui de la réforme
avec votre propre camp qui s'y oppose
plus finalement on a quasiment pas
entendu la droite sur les réseaux
sociaux par exemple non
la loi fait bouger les choses la loi
j'ai fait voter elle a fait bouger les
choses un petit peu parce que moi j'ai
mis volontairement
elle a mis volontairement et il y en a
qui a été modifié d'ailleurs deux qui
ont été modifiés c'est important mais
j'ai mis le volontairement les pieds
dans le plat sur le seuil des 50
pourquoi parce que je me suis aperçu
qu'il y avait deux fois plus
d'entreprises qui avaient 49 salariés
que l'entreprise qu'on avait 51 donc il
y avait une raison donc vu que la
méthode de ce gouvernement et je pense
que c'est la bonne méthode l'ADN de ce
gouvernement celui celles qui est voulue
par le président de la République c'est
le dialogue social dès que j'ai dit ça
bien évidemment j'ai rencontré
l'ensemble syndicale et patronale
patronales et syndical pour leur dire
pourquoi ne tentez-vous pas pourquoi ne
tentez-vous pas pour 3 ans d'effacer ce
seuil puisque de toute façon on voit
bien qu'il peut constituer un frein dans
l'évolution des entreprises ça ne peut
aider et je me suis heurté un refus de
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
donc j'ai repris ma proposition c'est
assez simple j'ai repris ma proposition
et j'ai avancé autrement j'ai avancé
avec le dialogue social vous avez avancé
beaucoup moins loin ben oui mais enfin
c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est pas une
révolution c'est une évolution et des
évolutions elles sont nécessaires à la
société
la société elle doit avancer par des
compromis et compromis c'est pas des
compromissions sont des accords qui sont
passés responsables gagnants gagnants et
là je peux vous dire que les chefs
d'entreprise m'appelle pour me dire
c'est bien ce que tu as fait entre 50 et
300 maintenant on a au lieu d'avoir 17
réunions on en a trois et c'est ça
change la vie dans une entreprise
françois-xamène est-ce que c'est
douloureux quand vous disiez tout à
l'heure par exemple pour les réseaux
sociaux vous disiez j'ai le pied dans le
plat un ministère un ministre mais
volontairement les pieds dans le plat
derrière en général c'est la curé
médiatique pendant 10 jours quand on est
dans son bureau au ministère on vit ça
comment parce qu'en gros on passe pour
un voilà quelqu'un qui se trompe qui va
trop loin qui n'est pas en ligne avec le
gouvernement qui qui va être obligé de
de battre en retraite on a la solidarité
de ces collègues
si on n'a pas de toute la gauche de la
gauche puisque c'est ce qui me puisse
dire
très fortes avec par exemple Gérard
Filoche c'est vrai bien sûr moi je vais
vous tapez très à gauche dans le Parti
Social oui mais il est c'est lui qui
critiquait les propositions que je
faisais essentiellement et donc puisque
la loi que j'ai présentée elle a été
votée christian Paul aussi qui est il a
voté la loi il a voté la loi que j'ai
présenté
on oublie ça cette loi que j'ai présenté
et votée par la gauche et pas que par la
gauche était voté par les écologistes
aussi et même j'ai senti que quelques le
Christ aurait pu la voter donc c'est des
lois comme ça qu'il faut prendre celle
qui rassemblent et pas celles qui
divisent mais ça n'empêche que on peut
par des annonces se faire bouger les
lignes et c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire bien pas bien on verra par exemple
j'ai supprimé la fiche individuelle du
compte pénibilité dans les petites
entreprises
j'ai un sujet de colère du patronat des
artisans des PME parce que les gros les
gros les grosses entreprises les grands
groupes ils ont pas de difficultés ils
ont les juristes ils ont tout mais
imaginez que dans une entreprise de
moins de 10 salariés aux salariés on
puisse suivre un salarié tous les jours
pour savoir combien de d'heures il a eu
les bras levés quand il fait de la
peinture par exemple mais mais c'est
avoir une fiche individuelle c'est juste
impossible donc ça a provoqué un tollé
quand j'ai annoncé que j'allais
supprimer l'affiche individuelle j'ai
supprimé la fiche individuel faut pas on
parler de moments de solitude tout à
l'heure vous en avez évoqué un lorsque
vous avez passé le relais à Myriam el
khomri au ministère du Travail c'est
vous l'avez dit le grand moment de
solitude de l'annonce des chiffres du
chômage
vous n'avez annoncé quasiment que des
hausses du chômage
j'ai annoncé la stabilisation
à la fin de l'année
à la fin de l'année le chômage aurait
été stabilisé dans notre pays et il va
commencer à baisser voilà durablement on
l'enregistre oui vous n'enregistrez je
reviens l'année prochaine et vous signez
sur ça qu'est-ce qui vous le fait dire
les chiffres de croissance qui sont
annoncés aujourd'hui moi moi j'ai vécu
moi le gouvernement avait eu pendant
trois ans
2012-2013 2014 trois années de
croissance quasi nulles il faut
s'imaginer ce que ça veut dire et le
ministre du Travail ne sert à rien
si mais non mais c'est là où il y a une
grosse
erreur j'ai fait une grande interview
dernièrement sur ce sujet le monsieur du
travail il n'a pas comme seul travail
d'annoncer les chiffres du chômage à la
fin du mois à la pourrait presque dire
que ces chiffres du chômage à la fin du
mois il pourrait être annoncé par le
ministre de l'Économie puisque c'est
uniquement la résultante quasiment
uniquement la résultante vous auriez
préféré oui mais je l'ai assumé bien sûr
je peux dire ça en souriant et il
n'empêche que le ministre du Travail
c'est le Ministre des salariés c'est le
Ministre du respect du droit du travail
c'est le ministre de la Formation
professionnelle c'est le Ministre du
dialogue social et donc tous ces
éléments qui font que aujourd'hui il y a
dans les entreprises 40000 accords
d'entreprises parce que il y a un cadre
qui est fixé donc c'est cela c'est aussi
de protéger les salariés de les défendre
le ministre du Travail ça a été des
grandes conquêtes sociales tout au long
de leur vie et je maintiens et je redis
que la loi que j'ai faite elle sera
aussi importante à la vaincre quand elle
va être en pratique elle commence à
entrer en pratique que les lois auront
en 1982 vous parlez d'indicateurs moi
j'en ai relevé un qu'on a reçu la
semaine dernière l'emploi intérimaire en
Bourgogne au mois d'août c'était plus
et est-ce que ça veut dire que si on
cumule ça avec plein d'autres
indicateurs économiques à les vendre de
voitures qui sont à plus neuf pour cent
je crois sur le mois dernier et en même
temps aujourd'hui les chefs d'entreprise
n'embauchent pas est-ce que ça veut dire
que les chefs d'entreprise ne jouent pas
le jeu en ce moment c'est quoi ils
attendent une alternance politique ils
ont peur de l'avenir vous ministre du
Travail vous avez forcément une théorie
là-dessus oui je vais même compléter
votre information en disant je l'ai
indiqué hier soir au préfet pour qu'ils
prennent les disposition j'ai écrit à la
Fédération du Bâtiment j'ai même des
lots de dans le cadre de marché public
qui ne trouve pas réponse c'est à dire
que les entreprises locales ne répondent
pas sur un lot par exemple je sais pas
le lot peinture pour le stade la tribune
par exemple tout ça ce sont des exemples
vrais et bien il y a pas eu de réponse
d'entreprise donc à un moment vous
proposer des questions comment est-ce
possible que des entreprises qui disent
que elles ont des difficultés à trouver
des marchés etc ne répondent pas à un
lot alors qu'on leur propose là du
travail et puis c'est pas des
excusez-moi des choses comme ça c'est
pas des petits lots c'est par là vous
posez la question et vous avez sûrement
une idée de la réponse c'est pas des
petits travaux non j'ai relancé bien sûr
j'ai écrit la Fédération du bâtiment et
puis il y a beaucoup de l'eau on a
qu'une seule réponse là c'est toujours
un peu étonnant c'est quoi c'est les
entreprises sont en modèle réduit elle
n'embauche pas elles veulent alors
j'essaie j'essaie de comprendre de les
aider à bouger je pense que les les
saillis que peut faire de temps en temps
sur Gattaz nuisent à la confiance des
entreprises le gouvernement a fait c'est
tenez vous bien c'est restituer les
marges que la droite a diminué pendant
10 ans évidemment ça fait pas plaisir
quand je dis ça mais moi je le dis
clairement de 2002 à 2012 les
entreprises industrielles elles ont vu
leur marge fortement diminuer et encore
plus sous la crise de 2008
avec certains d'entrepreneurs un patron
mais aussi des salariés c'est les
salariés de ce pays qui crée la richesse
et donc il faut que ces entreprises
elles puissent investir à nouveau voilà
donc il faut qu'elle retrouve cette
confiance qu'elles aient la certitude
que les choses vont aller mieux et on le
voit déficit en baisse aujourd'hui le
déficit budgétaire et en baisse à la fin
de l'année 2016 on sera revenu vous me
direz c'est pas très glorieux on sera
revenu au même état qu'en 2008 vous
voyez le chemin qu'il a fallu faire la
destruction 2008 2012 et la
reconstruction 2012-2016 ça permettra si
la courbe s'inverse à François Hollande
d'être candidat à sa propre succession
mais personnellement je le souhaite vous
savez c'est une c'était une première
question et est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on aurait pu imaginer un autre
scénario autrement dit est-ce que
François Hollande une manière ou d'une
autre aurait pu envisager de laisser sa
place en 2017 mais je crois qu'il faut
lui poser la question je suis je ne sais
pas quel est sa réponse aujourd'hui je
sais quel est son action il y a eu je
crois un mauvais départ dans ce
quinquennat les deux premières années
elles sont oui même le début le début je
pense que on a fait fi enfin je me mets
dedans les socialistes la gauche a fait
fi des difficultés c'est-à-dire n'a pas
assez insisté sur la gravité de la
situation à laquelle on était confronté
et se défaut de pédagogie du départ je
l'avais plusieurs dit plusieurs fois et
bien il s'est payé il se paye cher
aujourd'hui parce que il fallait mettre
les Français devant la réalité de la
situation qui avait été cachée par la
campagne présidentielle et ce qui peut
s'en relever François Hollande il est
quand même bas dans les enquêtes
d'opinion d'une manière quasiment jamais
vue sous la République Nicolas Sarkozy
était très bas aussi et François
Hollande est très bas il remonte
quasiment pas et il y a eu aussi des
affaires d'images on va dire qu'à
USA que l'affaire de vérité envers
toutes ces choses là est-ce que c'est
pas la personnalité du président qui est
opérée pour longtemps et est-ce qu'au
final il va se présenter parce qu'il l'a
dit et qu'il est président sortant mais
sans aucune chance de l'EMP il a pas il
a pas dit qu'il était candidat encore
donc sérieusement vous envisagez qu'il
ne le soit pas je pense je pense qu'il
peut ne pas l'être oui je pense qu'il
peut ne pas l'être je souhaite qu'il le
soit mais je pense qu'il peut ne pas
l'être ils sont son but c'est pas lui
c'est la France c'est rétablir
l'image de la France et je pense que
c'est des fautes communication qu'on
peut ne qu'on peut voir ils sont
aujourd'hui assez assez récurrent alors
que quand je le vois à l'international
comme j'ai accompagné le président des
sommets avec avec Poutine avec le
président chinois il y a un énorme
respect pour François Hollande il y a un
énorme respect pour la France mais nous
sommes aujourd'hui victimes dans ce pays
d'un
comment dire d'une offensive qui détruit
les fondements les bases démocratiques
de notre pays
ce que j'appelle le déclinisme le
défaitisme le pessimisme le French
bashing la France est un beau pays la
France est un grand pays elle a des
atouts elle a des entreprises
performantes on vend ce que n'avait pas
fait la droite on vendent des rafales on
vend de la technologie dans le monde
entier on est une grande un grand pays
mais 70% des Français pensent que leur
pays va mal alors que 70% pense qu'ils
vont bien pour eux-mêmes et il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas cette
dépression nerveuse de ce pays c'est le
fait qu'il n'y a plus aujourd'hui de
parole alors c'est relayé pas pas ici
mais c'est relayé par la par les médias
c'est relayé par les médias il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui des gens qui qui disent
mais ce pays à toutes les chances il va
se redresser mais bien sûr on a vécu
d'autres choses pendant la guerre les
périodes de reconstruction c'est un
grand pays mais je suis sidéré de voir
qu'il y a plus personne qui qui portent
des paroles d'espoir et d'optimisme et
qu'on cherche toujours à en rajouter
vous rendez compte que j'entendais sur
les sur les ondes ou à la télévision
dire il y a 6 millions de chômeurs en
France mais où c'est qu'on a vu ça où
c'est qu'on a vu ça il y a 10% de chômés
enfin c'est déjà suffisamment énorme
pour qu'on en rajoute pas vous savez que
la moyenne européenne c'est 11,5 mais
pourquoi chercher toujours à être plus
bas quand j'ai rencontré en tant que
ministre si vous me le permettez les
journalistes étrangers j'étais très
surpris il pensait que la France avait
un taux de chômage bien plus élevé que
l'ensemble de l'Europe pourquoi parce
que nous-mêmes on porte une image qui
est mauvaise image de notre pays alors
que c'est je le dis un GRAND un beau
pays un pays fort avec des entreprises
structurées innovantes qui n'exportent
peut-être pas c'est qui qui à cause du
climat pas la confiance il faut avoir
confiance est-ce que ce déclinisme on va
le sentir aussi dans quelques semaines
avec la prochaine échéance électorale
les élections régionales il y a eu de
fortes défaites pour le monsieur pour la
gauche les municipales les
départementales
les régionales c'est une proche à Dijon
c'est une seule chose je peux noter
quand même de façon générale les
régionales c'est une une nouvelle
déculottée pour la gauche qui s'annonce
est-ce que il y a un phénomène de lien
oui on s'aperçoit assez clairement que
quand on assume le pouvoir national on
perd les élections locales donc c'est
quasi mécanique ça a été la même chose
en négatif
toutes les régions étaient passées
toutes les régions étaient passées à
gauche ce qui n'était pas la vérité non
plus du pays mais quand même ce qui est
plus inquiétant c'est les dégâts qu'ont
provoqué dans notre société se
déclinissent d'effetismes se pessimisme
se rejet de l'autre cet individualisme
c'est la montée inexorable en ce moment
des populismes à travers le vote des
extrêmes mais je ne cite qu'un extrême
l'extrême droite donc là je suis très
inquiet comment comment notre notre
peuple si si intelligent si cultivait si
formait peut-il se laisser aller à un
tel rejet des fondements même de l'idéal
démocratique ni notre pays c'est ces
questions
pourrais pas donner envie de mener cette
bataille on dit que votre nom a été
testé sur des sondages sur la région
est-ce que François Hollande aurait aimé
que vous vous me meniez la bataille en
Bourgogne Franche-Comté jeune pouvais
pas
mener cette bataille en étant ministre
du Travail vous auriez pu arrêter comme
vous l'avez fait pour revenir à Dijon
non parce que ce n'est pas la ce n'est
pas la même chose que de tenir un
engagement pris vis-à-vis des électeurs
j'ai été élu maire de Dijon quand même
je voudrais rappeler avec 53% des voix
en triangulaire donc
la gauche a été majoritaire dans cette
communauté urbaine elle est jusqu'en
2020 quoi qu'il se passe je dis ça à
ceux qui sont à peu pressés qui prennent
leur temps et ils vont falloir il va
falloir qu'il s'habitue à me revoir et
donc non c'était pas du tout la même
chose mais c'est vrai que c'est un beau
combat amené c'est vrai que c'est un bon
combat et Marinette du fait était la
seule femme sortante présidente de
région là aussi c'est un beau symbole
quand même de la soutenir c'est bien
vous avez d'un côté une femme présidente
de région qui a ce mandat le seul
mandataire c'est la bonne candidate
Marie Dufays que François Patriot aurait
pas été meilleur candidat François
Patriat il a déjà été deux fois candidat
il a pas voulu l'être bien sûr je vous
dise donc marine Dufay c'est une bonne
candidate et elle va faire une surprise
j'en suis sûr
on est dans la période toujours
compliquée de la constitution des Lices
il y a un certain nombre de
vice-présidents socialistes du conseil
régional qui ne seront pas sur la liste
socialiste on pense à sa fille à tokoré
a fadilakatabi il y a des rhumes de
constitution de liste dissidente qui
pourrait mélanger la droite et la gauche
c'est un c'est un vrai danger pour pour
la majorité socialiste actuelle et pour
les grandes listes en général c'est un
moment très moi j'ai eu à faire ses
constitutions de liste par le passé
c'est un moment extrêmement difficile
vous avez poussé beaucoup de dijonnaises
sur les la liste côte d'Orient c'est
vrai bah finalement quand on regarde ce
que représente Dijon et sa communauté
urbaine c'est à peu près la moitié du
département donc vous voyez il doit y
avoir la fabriquer des mondes de la
communauté urbaine et puis vu qu'on est
sur représenté par rapport au monde
rural où on est sous représenté il est
normal je pense qu'il y en a même
peut-être pas assez voilà mais c'est pas
c'est pas facile de faire des listes moi
je regrette que Fadila katabi n'est pas
accepté la place qui lui était proposée
c'était une place tout à fait
respectable tout à fait juste je
respecte son choix bien sûr mais je le
regrette elle a fait un travailleur
formidable au conseil régional était
directement en lien avec moi avec mon
ministère à travers la formation
professionnelle donc on a agi ensemble
donc je le regrette mais on a une belle
liste forcément il y a toujours des gens
qui sont écartés et qui c'est dur c'est
dur la vie publique merci Françoise
Harlem pour la première partie de cette
émission on va bien sûr parler de Dijon
dans la deuxième partie puisque votre
premier conseil municipal puis votre
retour c'était lundi tout de suite les
informations de midi avec elles a besoin
et nous on se retrouve juste après je
vous le disais pour parler de Dijon pour
parler du dossier de la cité de la
gastronomie par exemple et puis des des
grands projets à venir à tout de suite